when delivery driver matt was pinged by
the nhs kovid 19 app
unlike millions of britons he didn't
have to self-isolate
he's one of around 10 000 food workers
covered by a test and release
exemption so as long as matt tests
negative every day
he's free to work it was good to be able
to carry on life as normal
and because once you've had your test
you know you're safe to the customers
and for your family as well so
it was it was better than better than
staying at home in my opinion because
you could just
carry on
[Music]
they pick 100 000 items on every shift
at this north london depot
one of 15 food distribution sites
prioritized
under the government's exemption scheme
john lewis and waitrose have been part
of the government trial of direct
contact testing around 5 000 members of
staff
have been tested and 98 of them
have tested negative that is a lot of
staff we've been able to keep working
keeping the shelves stacked and making
sure the food gets out to customers
while matt and his colleagues are free
to keep working hundreds of thousands of
others
are still facing self-isolation in the
week to july 21st a record 689
313 people were pinged by the app in
england and wales
up 11 on the previous week and almost
600 000 people were identified as close
contacts by nhs test and trace though
some cases may overlap with the app
it's the highest figure since january
what we have outlined is quite a
significant
set of exemptions for critical
industries critical workforces to enable
that essential part of our economy to
keep functioning but what i say to
people is look i know it's frustrating
please stick with it
it's just a few more weeks
there's no exemption for hospitality
businesses like emica and ife's
restaurant
reopening after a week of forced closure
i think the point
um is how long will this continue to go
on for you know
it's gone on for much longer than people
expected and even
as you know restrictions are lifted it's
not
back to normal the holidays may have
begun but there'll be no break from
isolation even after august the 16th for
those who've only had one
vaccine many of them under 30. for
hospitality the challenge is 60
of our workforce is under 30 so through
no fault of their own
they're not double vaccinated so we are
continuing to push the government
to ask for those workers to be able to
have a test to remain scheme
so that they can stay in work without
compromising safety
hi guys do you want your cruising
vaccine today at thorpe park
they're trying to fill the vaccine gap
with a pop-up center
for now only two jabs will guarantee
jobs
but with weekly average cases now
falling there is hope the pandemic
may have peaked too paul kelso sky news
in north london